[Music]
welcome to the last day last show you're
just saving the best for the last
my name is Gopal Ashok I'm a product
manager for cloud memory store I also
have here with me Karthi Tiago Rajan who
is a cloud architect in Google cloud
platform today we're going to talk about
cloud memory store and talk about you
know cashing in general in Google cloud
platform first of all thank you for
being here you know at the end of the
conference after three days it's I'm
pretty sure it's pretty tiring but we
really appreciate you all being here
hopefully we can make this a productive
session for you one of the things that I
like to do as I do the session is to
keep the session interactive so if you
have questions please feel free to raise
your hand and if appropriate we can take
the questions as we go along
oh please use a microphone when asking
this question so that we can record the
questions student all right let's get
started before I jump into the topics I
just want to kind of lay the framework
for the talk what I'm going to talk
today about is cloud memory store as a
product of what we are offering we will
deep dive into some of the features of
the managed service that we are offering
and finally we will bring it all
together by showing how you can build
applications deploy a build deploy and
also more importantly monetary
applications when using globe memory
store so before I jump into the product
itself I just want to take a quick step
back for me this chart is a little a
little bit interesting a lot of you may
be familiar with DB engines DB engines
is a website that basically tracks the
popularity of the different databases
that are currently in use when you look
at this chart you can actually you know
make a lot of different inferences in
this chart depending on which I you know
you used to look at a chart but for me
the key thing here is the number of
different databases that are currently
popular right and the number of
different types of databases that are
currently being used to build
applications and this is not surprising
right when you look at the different
kinds of use cases that have all
over the last 10 years it's very clear
that you know using a single relational
database was not going to cut it and the
reason being different application use
cases a different access patterns
different query patterns so using just
relational database even if the
relational database at different data
models was not optimal so we're a period
of time different kinds of databases
came into to the market and one of the
key trends that we're seeing is this
notion of polyglot persistence I just
like the world polyglot sound like I
have to use this but more importantly
what we see is the shift words are more
of more adoption of microservices based
architecture and what that means then is
when you use micro-services based
architecture one of the key design
patterns is that you basically have
different databases
you know purpose-built databases for
water specific micro services using so
quick question how many of you use more
than or just one database in the
applications that you currently have
what about let's say three so the the
key point here is that with Microsoft's
architecture on or not if even if you're
not the the management of databases
become start becoming a lot more complex
right when you use different kinds of
databases now you'd need to have new
skill sets that you need to have even if
you can standardize some of the
automation or deployment etc there are
still nuances across all these different
databases what you want to be able to do
is just spend time building applications
and less time you know managing the
infrastructure so that's where in the
context of this talk but managed
services and manage database services
helps when you you know move into a
cloud platform so the key thing about
Manor service is that it helps you focus
on the logical side of things in terms
of building applications and you know we
take care of the physical aspects of
managing the database so in that context
from google cloud provides a wide
variety of managed database services and
if you have attended you know since it's
the last session i'm pretty sure you've
attended a lot of the database talks and
you probably have seen the slide but the
point here is that regardless of what
database you're using in google cloud we
offer
services either provided by Google or
through our partner services so if you
look at you know just a quick look at
the different databases that we offer on
the non-relational side we have cloud
datastore is this kind of a document DB
BigTable is a white column store and
with relational we have cloud sequel
which is essentially Postgres and my
sequel and spanner which is a highly
scalable globally distributed database
today what I want to do is focus on
cloud memory store so what is cloud
memory store so cloud memory store which
is currently in beta we release a
product back in May and we are currently
in beta is a fully managed in-memory
data store service for Redis right so
it's a fully managed offering that
supports Redis so why is this important
so if you ask anybody who builds loss
scale applications in memory caching is
a fundamental piece of that art you know
application architecture I don't think
we need to spend a lot of time you know
kind of evaluating the the benefit of
caching but if you look at where caching
is applicable you know there's a wide
variety of use cases where caching is
truly beneficial you know from a very
simple in a web application to anything
like at Tech right where you're serving
real time or in the real time bidding
infrastructure so across the board we
know that in an in-memory store that
provides you know extremely low latency
query processing becomes extremely
beneficial or it's actually a
requirement these days to have a cache
in place now what are the different
types of caches that are that people
normally use there are two types of
caches that are very popular today the
most popular one is Redis and then
there's memcache right memcache has been
around for a long time we actually are
Brad here who weren't there on the
initial versions of memcache but Redis
has become a lot more popular the reason
Redis has become a lot more popular is
because apart from you know the
performance aspects that it gives
because it's an in-memory store it is
mostly referred to as a data structure
server right so memcache essentially
allows you to still
like key values and they you know
provides you quick access to static data
but rhetta's provides built-in data
structures so it actually expands a set
of use cases that that can be used and
you know some of the things like sorted
sets are very popular for building
gaming applications like you're building
leaderboards sorted sets becomes
extremely useful and there's lists and
there's hashes so there's a variety of
data structures that make it a very
powerful in-memory store but apart from
that I think one of the issues with
memcache was that if you really relied
on a cache I mean if you want a
durability of keys memcache was not
really the best solution for it so with
Redis you have persistence we also have
replication so if you really want to
build a highly resilient cache or or
in-memory store Redis is actually a good
choice for that apart from that it also
supports pops up right so if you want to
build like notification systems etc
right as gives you that capability and
also scripting right all on and all this
that you know really really fast
performance so over a period of time
Redis has become extremely popular so a
quick question how many of you actually
use memcache Wow
quite a bit what about Redis so it's
it's kind of it's interesting for us in
terms of when you look at should we do
Raddatz or should we do the memcache
right it should be or should we provide
both but it's interesting to see that
it's an equal proportion of you know
both Redis in memcache and I think
there's reasons why memcache sometimes
is much more useful for certain use
cases compared to read us okay so with
call memory store we provide Redis as
the engine the key thing that we've been
trying to do with cloud memory store
like I said is that with managed
services what we try to do is we try to
take the burden a wave of managing Redis
yourself and if you ask anybody who's
you know deployed read is there's a lot
of things that goes into managing
something on your own right even as
simple as things like patching for
example so with our managed services we
take care of essentially deploying Redis
and gives you an endpoint and all you
need to do is basically worry about
writing applications against it the key
thing I want to say here is that we are
built on open source reddit so we don't
have we are not building anything Google
proprietary we are simply taking the
open source Aretas and exposing it as a
managed service the other couple of the
other key things that we wanted to focus
on was how do we provide a highly
reliable and highly available service so
in the offering which I'll get into in a
little bit more detail
we provide replication we provide fast
automatic failover and we also provide
an available T SLA all right so that's
something that normally you don't see
but we will be having that once we go GA
with respect to replication and
automatic failure where you know
sentinel is a common way to set up high
you know replicated Redis but there's a
lot of complexity in terms of deploying
sentimental and managing it so in the
memory store you don't have to worry
about all those things we basically take
care of things in terms of how we do
health checking everything is done for
you
and finally scalability and security
with memory store one of the things
again one of her focus is how can we
make things easier for you so we've made
put in a lot of work to make scaling
super easy because what are some of the
use cases that we see with customers is
essentially spikes right for example we
have a retail customer where you know
during Black Friday or any of their peak
retail or shopping days it's very
unpredictable so it's great for us to be
able to be sure that they can actually
scale up and as needed without having to
go through a lot of pain so that's kind
of built provided in the service the
other key thing is that Redis you know
in a way is not very secure out of the
box right so they all be out it's it's
always a recommendation that don't put
Redis you know out there in the public
so what we do is we deploy red is on a
private IP so it's not really accessible
from anywhere else other than from
within the Google Network or we use
network based authentication or network
based security to limit access to the
reticence and so there's an additional
level of security there and also we
provide role based access control ready
for the administrative side of things so
bottom line is you know it's a fully
managed service that allows you to just
you know easily deploy Redis and use it
and we have customers currently using it
and it's it's seen a pretty good
adoption in terms of a memory store and
it wasn't surprising because everybody
wants a cache and everybody you know
Redis is a very popular engine that
customers use so we've been actually
getting pretty good responses from
customers okay so let's dive in a little
bit into what the offering itself is and
what we have right now in beta so one
thing I want to clarify is that whatever
I'm talking about right now is what is
available like today in the beta release
and this is our v1 release right so the
way we are exposed to service is through
you know two tiers we have a basic tier
and a standard tier so the basic tier is
a single Redis instance and we see a lot
of customers just using the basic tier
because in lot of the use cases the very
simple cache right the key thing that
you want to be you know kind of be aware
of with basic instances like any other
instance of read a single instance of
Redis is that we if this instance goes
down it's a full cache flashlight for
any reason behind the scenes something
happens we will make we will make sure
that it comes back up but you will
experience a full cache flush but that's
some of the advantages you have because
now we do the health check and when we
bring back the instance we preserve the
IP address in some cases when you're
deploying your own those are some of the
challenges that you run into whether you
can actually reserve the same IP address
you know when an instance comes back up
so all that is kind of taken care of
we don't provide an SLA for basic tier
but in the SATA tier if we provide a
replicated version of Redis we have a
cross zone replication and we provide
automatic failover the other key thing
is that you only connect you connect to
a single endpoint and we make sure that
the traffic is directed to the right
white instance our bright location so in
both the cases for both basic and
standard here the key thing to remember
is that it's a single mouse
right so even in the standard tier
there's one master it is not a scale out
model yet so that's something to keep in
mind when you are use the service and
like I said we will be providing three
nines of availability once we go GA
right now we are in beta so the SLA
don't apply but when we go ga
we will provide three nines of
availability okay so provisioning one of
the things that we do is to try to make
things really simple but we also
understand that you know using UI is not
the only way folks want provision or
they services nowadays with
infrastructure as a code becoming you
know more and more of the standard way
to manage your infrastructure you know
there are different ways to do it
so with cloud memory store we not you
know we obviously support the UI SDK etc
but we also support cloud deployment
manager or deployment manager and also
terraform so if you're using terraform
to manage your infrastructure you can
use that to manage a memory store for
the beta version we are supporting Redis
3.2.2 Levin one of the things that I you
know talking about usefulness of managed
service is one of the things that I
forgot to mention is you know recently
I'm not sure if you're aware already
said a recent security vulnerability
that was announced I think last month so
the key thing is that you know we
actually applied the patch even before
the vulnerability became public right so
those those are some of the things that
you know we get to do behind the scenes
so that you don't have to worry about
those things
so the 3.2.1 that we have today is you
know it's a Redis version that is fully
patched of with the latest of fix okay
so going to the next level in terms of
how we expose the service what we allow
you to do is we just allow you to
provision any size from 1gb to 300 GB
right at 1gb increment but the way the
service is steered is that the higher
the memory size you get better
throughput right so and also this m1 m3
m5 tiering essentially not only captures
the the network performance but also
relates to how we price the service so
in this particular table what you see
the ranges that we that we provide and
the corresponding network throughput so
if you need higher throughput you
basically have to build provisional more
memory based on your needs but Redis
being single threaded we know we
provision enough CPUs in the background
that unless it's for certain workloads
you know our network may become the
troop may become the bottleneck so what
yeah what we recommend is that you know
profile your workload run the benchmarks
and see what works best for you
but the way we are exposed to service is
essentially using capacity tiers and
from a pricing perspective we price the
service and gigabyte ours so for the
different ranges we have fixed gigabyte
our pricing and so when he went
somewhere nice it's a gigabyte hour to
somebody else like what is the pricing
per hour so the pricing per hour is
essentially a multiplier of the gigabyte
our price times the amount of gigabyte
you're provisioning for that tier so for
example if you're provisioning like four
gigs of memory it'll be four times you
know four point nine cents or your
provisioning like hundred gigs it's a
hundred times one point nine cents right
so and we have a pricing calculator that
will that can that'll easily let you
figure out what the pricing is in terms
of them per hour pricing but the key
thing here is that you know we give you
the flexibility you know depending on
what you want from a cache we give you
the flexibility whether it's the single
instance highly available instance or
different throughput characteristics etc
okay so what I want to do now is go to
the demo and show you how walk you
through the walk you through the
provisioning process and I just want to
dive into some of the details of of the
managed service and some of the things
that you may want to know about when
you're designing applications on top of
memory store
okay so memory store is a storage
product and it can be found under the
storage menu for in the Google Cloud
console so what you see here is that's a
few instances that we have provisioned
so let me let me walk you through our
creation of an instance and I want to
kind of talk through some of the nuances
about the service so I'm gonna provision
an instance here let's say for instance
ID is essentially identifier of the
instance um so like I mentioned earlier
the version that we expose is 3.2 mm
immediately we get the question a are
you going to support 4.0 the answer is
yes it's off you're going to add 4.0
pretty soon but right now if you're
provisioning memory store you get 3.2 or
you get to choose it here like I
mentioned basically standard here and
the locations that we have currently
exposed we are exposed we have the
services available in five regions today
we are well aware of the fact that you
know there are more regions and we need
to be there so that's something that we
are working on getting more regions
added very quickly so what do you see
here when you select the region
essentially is memory store is a
regional service so what that means is
that when you deploy in a particular
region you can connect applications are
can connect from any zone from you know
it's a regional service so you can
connect from within that same region we
today don't support cross region access
right so if you are applications trying
to connect from another region or two
memory store in a different region we
don't allow you to that that is not
enabled yet so in the key we give you
the option to you know deploy your
application in any specific zone one
thing I want to note about pricing is
that we don't charge for Network like
memories or doesn't have network charge
right but we do charge for for example
if your application is in zone a and
memory stores in Zone B and if you're
connecting from GCE GCE has a cross net
crawls on networking charge so if you if
that traffic exists then you will be
charged on the GCE side for that cross
zone
crawls on network traffic so that's
something to keep in mind and over here
you basically again like I said you can
provision anywhere from 1 to 300 GB and
depending on what size you select
obviously you know you can see that the
network throughput changes and how much
network throughput you can get you know
changes with the size so let's go and
pick us a number of 30 gig and finally
the network so the way we authenticate
access to the memory store is using V PC
so you pick a specific network that
you're going to deploy memory store in
and we restrict access to memory store
for for that particular network so what
that means is that any application or
any VMs on that specific network can
access this particular instance and
finally from a Redis configuration
perspective we haven't exposed too many
parameters yet we exposed to max memory
policies one of them I believe wallet
LRU is our default so this is something
that you may want to think about
configuring when you actually deploy
memory store based on you know what you
want to do and that's it right so once
you do that you basically click create
and you know you go ahead and peek over
and create the instance for you so like
I said when you create the instance what
you get is an IP it's a private IP that
you get on the 63 79 port and I
mentioned that you know Redis is fully
protocol compatible so you know I can
use Redis CLI I hope you can see it and
be born
you know commands just like you would do
in any Redis instance right so it's a
fully open oh it's it's an open source
right as so all that is compatible I
would say though that from a managed
services perspective we do blocks and
commands um so we have documented what
those commands are but those commands
are primarily some of the admin commands
that we are blocked from the from the
application side of things you know we
support Lewis scripting we support
pub/sub so all that you know is fully
available of when you use memory store
okay let's go back to the slides
so from a best-practice perspective like
I said right you have the options if
you're if you're using it as a simple
cache basic tear will definitely work
for you one thing I would note is that
the basic tear we do have regular
maintenance that happens you know on a
quarterly basis or whenever we have to
apply any patches critical patches if
you're using a basic tear you can't
experience a full cache flush and events
like that right but standard here what
we do is we do a rolling upgrade so we
you have higher availability on events
like that right because we just apply
the patch on a rolling manner the other
key thing that I want to point out is
persistence so in the beta release we
haven't enabled persistence when I say
persistence I'm talking about a o F and
I'm also talking about our dB we haven't
enabled either one of them yet on the
basic or Santa cheer we are working on
the ability to import and export data to
a GCS bucket that will be coming soon
we are also looking at a of persistence
which is probably further down the road
from an instant sizing perspective like
I said you know there are various
benchmarks that are currently available
I'm sure if you're already using Redis
you're an idea of the workload a pattern
that you have you know always run the
benchmarks to see what size fits for you
like I said as higher the size the
better the throughput that you get so
you may want to do that I've talked
about the eviction policy a little bit
and also the configuration so we have
documented all the default
configurations that we use like I said
we don't allow you to change a lot of
the configurations or many of the
configurations so it's good to know what
are the configurations that we set by
default for these memory store instances
how many of you actually do scale their
instances often nobody so scaling is
something that we have been able in beta
it's a very simple way to scale a system
you basically change the size how does
the behavior work in basic tier it is a
full flush of the cache and insanity R
we basically do a rolling
upgrade or when we do the scaling we do
it in a in a highly available manner so
from an application perspective what
that means is that the only time the
applications unavailable if you're using
standard here is when you when we do the
failover and the failover that we do is
actually very quick it's probably in the
30 second range and we have some
heuristics in the back for replication
but having said that talking about
replication we use Redis replication
under the cover so that means it's an
asynchronous replication so when you do
scaling or venue operation it's quite
possible that there could be some
unreplicated data or there could be some
data that is stale because the changes
were not replicated when the failover
happened so that's that is instant
scaling and I just wanted to take a
quick moment and see if folks have any
questions about the things that I talked
about till now
do you mind using the mic
um so I think one of the themes that's
been running through a lot of the talks
I've been to it this conference has been
like don't trust the network make sure
you authenticate your peers the whole
service mesh thing but this service
seems to from what I can see be mostly
have VPC level security are there any
plans to like tie this into I am or TLS
or something so we can authenticate the
clients and right so you write that
currently it is we PCB security and one
of the things I'd be working on is
initially at least enable all right but
again that's just right as password but
beyond the ideas we are looking at same
at least figuring out how to do you know
encrypted connections between the client
and server so that's something
definitely on the on the roadmap Thanks
on premise what do you mean so are you
talking about connectivity or already
talking about weather so you want to be
able to connect to memory store from on
Prem using let's say a VPN or something
like that
we haven't can you tell me a little bit
more about the because you know from a
caching perspective latency is a
critical factor right so I'm curious in
your in that hybrid case is it more for
migration or is it what is a use case
there
for is it Redis or memcache okay um so
the two questions are right I think two
parts of the question one is in how do
you connect from on Prem on to Club
memory store against that's something
not that we haven't enabled yet we you
know we have it we're trying to figure
out see how many you know customers
actually needed but we do see the use
case for it in terms of the terabyte
size cache and like I mentioned today we
have the basic and standard here which
is a single instance and the replicated
instance again single master you're
right it's 300 GP from a terabyte cache
perspective we are looking at the next
thing we are working on is clustering so
if you do scale out Redis clusters so
when you have when we ask a lot of Redis
cluster you know you should be able to
provide terabytes of provision terabytes
of cache so that's something that we are
working on but you're right that
currently it is limited to 300 GB we may
increase our number a little bit more
but we are still conference constrained
by that single you know VM deployment
yes that was my next topic
one more question please okay so am I to
understand that because you're using
asynchronous replication in a fell over
event in general not just in a scaling
that's correct so yes any time there is
a feel aware you can have that one of
the things that we are planning to
promote today we don't provide a
failover
API that you can manually figure or so
if you're doing like manual furloughs
once you have the API then you can
control you know whether something is
since you know whether the instances are
isn't sync and then failover in that
case obviously there won't be any but
unplanned yes you can't expect
unreplicated data and some how long
would a failover event be expected to
last like here when it's planned it's
about 30 seconds apparently but if it's
unplanned about how long would that
period of strangeness and possible and
availability be so different scenarios
right if it is a complete
essentially we expect it to be less than
a minute right if it's an unplanned
because essentially we're not waiting
for transactions to be replicated or
commands to be replicated in the case of
scaling we actually have a heuristic
where we wait for the replicas to get
caught up right and then do the feet
over but then the figure over time is
still no less than a minute okay so let
me there's a question on monitoring so
let me quickly go back to the slides and
talk about monitoring a little bit so we
do have integrator monitoring so what
that means is that we are we are
integrated with stackdriver so we export
all our metrics from the instances into
stackdriver
you can use stackdriver to basically do
the server-side monitoring right so let
me quickly show you what we have today
from a climate perspective switching to
the demo so if you go into sacra where
it's a little bit zoomed I'm going to
zoom in a little bit so if you go into
metrics Explorer in stackdriver and if
you look for memory store so your memory
store brightest instance and underneath
that we have exposed a whole bunch of
metrics that you can use to monitor your
instances so what I've done is we
haven't yet have an integrated dashboard
but you can go and create a dashboard
yourself and this is one thing that I've
dashboard that I've created so as you
can see you basically can build your own
dashboards and monitor the the instance
cloud memories for instance from stack
drivers so we have that integrated
monitoring and the other thing is that
if you are using your own tools you
should be able to get the metrics out of
memory store because you're fully
protocol compliant one thing you may
want to test is if there is any other
block commands that we are using blocks
any of the tools we would be happy to
you know kind of take a look at that and
see if we need to do something there but
we haven't had any yet in terms of those
commands blocking the usage of
third-party tools but like I said with
stack driver monitoring you get all the
metrics
the regicide like network throughput CP
utilization one of the interesting
things that you can do also is you can
monitor the create alerts for specific
metrics and basically allowed to you for
one of the good examples of like memory
usage ratio right so if you want to be
able to be sure that your instance is
not running out of memory you can
actually set an alert and card these are
actually going to demo this in asset
section I believe and you know also do a
lot based monitoring so going back to
the slide so monitoring the server-side
monitoring is interesting right so it
gives you a bunch of data but it Souls
really doesn't can we go back to slide
please oh if you're back on the slide so
it still doesn't give you an -
invisibility in terms of what's
happening from an application
perspective right a lot of the times you
struggle when you have a latency problem
or the application side you can come and
look at you know the server side metrics
but you're still not sure what's going
on right unless there was something
obvious that's going on on the server
side it becomes extremely hard to
troubleshoot so the interesting thing
and one of the things that Google has
been trying to do and Google has
actually open source is open census
right how many of you use open census
today right so open census is
essentially you know a distribution of
libraries that basically allows you to
collect traces and metrics from your
application right it's a super powerful
framework or a live set of libraries
that we that be able source and one of
the things that we've been doing
internally is to base instruments some
of the Redis clients that are out there
and see how it all works but at a high
level what open census does is it
basically allows you to use the
libraries and bees inject your own or
export your own metrics from your
application perspective so depending on
what your application does you can
define what matters is that latency is
it transactions per second whatever it
is but at the application level right so
that and then what you can do is the
open census exports it into some other
popular monitoring and tracing tools one
of them being stack driver
right so now you have n2 invisibility
notices from the server side but also
from the application side so this makes
troubleshooting extremely extremely much
more easier and provides end-to-end
visibility compared to just having
server side metric so having said that
what we want to do right now is to show
you how you can actually bring all these
things together so Karthi is going to
kind of walk you through how you can
build applications do you know build
deploy and actually monitor application
also using open census
thanks Gopal can everyone hear me
great so let me actually move to the
next slide as Gopal mentioned the
engineering team responsible for memory
story they've done a great job surfacing
all the metrics that you just saw you
guys are able to see latency errors
things of that nature on the server side
so what we're gonna see next is how can
we instrument our own application with
an emphasis on using memory store so
I'll talk about a simple application
architecture that's a three-tier
application that uses Java and we're
also going to use a traditional database
in this case my sequel on top of cloud
sequel and we'll also get into
deployment and provisioning so I have a
quick conformal survey here for
provisioning you know we're gonna be
using terraform and kubernetes as the
topology so how many of you are using
terraform and kubernetes across your
applications great so it'll be relevant
to a good number of people happy to see
that this is the simple three-tier
application that I talked about as you
can see we have a you know in this case
it's a single single page application
that uses view j/s it's gonna talk
through our global HTTP load balancer
into a Java spring API hosted on top of
gke that application is in turn going to
talk to
cloud cloud sequel my sequel in this
case and essentially this application
which I'll demo in a little bit we'll
look up employees in our organization
and catch those results into memory
store for Redis and the hope is you'll
get really low latency because or after
it's been cashed because you're using an
in-memory cache a little bit about
infrastructure as code as Gopal
mentioned we'll be using infrastructures
code I mean this is all the rage these
days it makes DevOps a whole lot easier
you know we can do cool things like
configuration management keep track of
what our resources are all that good
stuff is everybody familiar or are most
people familiar with VPC and you know
the whole notion of networking on GC on
GC P so assuming that what we're gonna
do is we're gonna deploy a gke cluster
into our V PC this is a separate V PC
set aside for our application and into
the same V PC we're gonna deploy a
memory store instance this instance as
Gopal mentioned has to be in the same V
PC so that we isolate traffic to that
instance from from any other resources
that may be trying to access it we also
have a whole bunch of other GC GCP
resources that we'll be using and I'll
get into it in a little bit on the
terraform side you know this is
something that our product teams have
been really good at we every time we
release a product we ensure that there's
deployment management deployment manager
support as well as terraform support in
this case it's fairly straightforward to
declaratively define our Redis instance
or memory store instance the two things
that I'll call out here are as you can
see there's an authorized Network
specify there that network is the same
as the gke cluster that I'm gonna show
you in a little bit the other thing that
I'll call out is the fact that there's a
reserved IP range this keep thing keeps
things clean we're documenting the IP
range we're going to be using for our
Redis instance as well as our pods in
the gke cluster and here's our gke
cluster the only thing I'll call out
here is the fact that I'm specifying an
IP allocation policy and the reason for
doing that is because we're using gke we
have to enable IP aliasing in order for
our pods to be able to talk to memory
store this is an extra step that you
have to do as opposed to if you were
deploying a simple VM and having that
talk to your memory store instance not
much else to do there but in this case
you have to enable IP aliasing the steps
for this might look a little different
if you're provisioning these resources
using let's say G cloud or a deployment
manager and I also want to call out the
fact that I'm gonna go back a couple of
slides all the resources that you see
here can be deployed with Google
deployment manager as well I'm choosing
to use terraform here okay with that
said let's get into the demo thankfully
my machine has not locked awesome
so actually the first step that I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna show you that I
can get into I can have a pod on my jke
cluster talk to the memory store
instance as Gopal showed you earlier I'm
just gonna refresh your memory on this
we have three instances these are all
for the purposes of our demo and they're
all deployed into different V pcs and
even if you see you know some of those
instances having the same IP address
don't get confused they're all in
different V pcs that's why they you know
they have the same IP address so we know
that we want to be able to ping from our
pod 10.04 so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to connect to connect to the jump
pod where I have read is CLI deployed it
happens to be called my sequel client
because that's also where the my sequel
client is and I connect to it and let's
spin up ready CLI
that's the IP address as I mentioned and
I can list the characteristics of that
instance so all good and this is what
you would do in your application as well
and once there let me flush the cache so
that I can get the demo to work as
expected cool so now let me go to the
demo and kind of show you it's pretty
simple it's an application that once
again as I said it allows you to look up
the employees in your organization I am
going to start typing in Gopal and
there's one step that I have to do we
have a we have something called beyond
Corp that interferes with my demo I'm
going to turn that off and now let me
type in gopal and what this demo has is
in addition to all the names that it
brings back it also shows you how long
that request took hopefully all of you
can see this in this case it took 539
milliseconds now the hope is it's been
cached I type in GOP again and refresh
this just for good measure it took much
less time and I know that's not very
convincing
what we're gonna do is is go fall
mention we're gonna use open census
which I'll show you the code for we're
gonna use open census to see what
happened during that call path as we as
that call progressed for this I will
switch to my Google Cloud console let me
pull up the console here so just so you
guys can go to this console on your own
this is under the stackdriver trace menu
and i'm gonna look at the trace list and
let me make this a little bit smaller
because it's hard to see this was my
initial call I typed in GOP for Gopal
and you can see that this call started
at the get employees method and it
actually shows you how long that method
538 milliseconds or so but the cool
thing here is so you can tell that this
call actually looked up or tried to look
up that keyword in Redis we're using the
Jetta sly Barry here and I'll talk a
little bit about how that library is
instrumented but it didn't find that
keyword so then it had to go to my
sequel and it also shows you how long
that my sequel call took and you can
tell the bulk of the time was in the my
sequel call execute query etc it found
the entry and then it put the results of
that request into our cache so something
straightforward you know that that most
people do in a caching type environment
so you can kind of see what happened
right this is the happy path this is
what you expect to happen so now let's
go back to our trace list and just
confirm that once it's been cached I
type in the same keyword in this case
hey it pulled it out of the cache and it
took a lot less time and you can see
that it didn't have to go to my sequel
so that's the happy path let's actually
Oh before I go back and introduce an
error let me also show you in addition
to tracing the cool thing that open
census does is it also lets you surface
metrics I had a whole bunch of metrics
shown here but unfortunately a whole
bunch of time as a laughs so this is
what happened from my most recent query
you can see you know things like heat
map so you get a sense of you know what
your queries are doing in an aggregate
you can also see a linear view of what
your queries are doing in addition to
that you can surface errors from your
jettison I mean you're whatever read is
library you're using in this case I've
instrumented Jettas and I'll show you
how to surface those errors as well
before I do that let me show you the the
code real quick this is can everybody
see this okay is it too small
hopefully it's big enough this is the
get employees call that I mentioned it's
my spring brute controller and you know
I'm importing the appropriate open
census libraries gopal showed you where
to get that library
and I'm using something called something
called the tracer class and I set up a
span and in that span I can put in you
know annotations that show me you know
which particular method was called any
data that was passed into that method in
this case the keyword that was supplied
and I can trace internal or methods that
are internal to that call as well in
this case I've also instrumented get
from cache I've added an annotation that
says cache miss in case there's a cache
miss let me show you that real quick go
back to this and you can see that that
annotation shows up in my stretch driver
console so it's pretty straightforward
to annotate your code with open senses
the other thing I'll call out is the
fact that you're seeing going back to
this real quick you're seeing all this
stuff from the Jettas library like
Jettas dot protocol dot bulk process
multiply Redis client status not close
all that stuff
I didn't instrument that in my code that
came from the instrumentation that is in
the library that I'm using so out of the
box you know obviously the Jettas
library is not going to give you this
instrumentation and and I'll show you
where to get that instrumented library
but for your own needs if you're using a
version of Jetta [ __ ] or a Redis library
for whatever language you're using look
for it in this place if it's not there
you can obviously fairly easily
instrumented it and contribute it back
to the community let me see how much
time we have we have a little bit more
time to show the air condition that I
described so how do you surface you know
errors that you may that you may see so
for that what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
trigger this this thing that essentially
has my application talked to a
non-existent Redis hose so now I'm gonna
type in Gopal even though Gopal was
cashed you can see that it's still
taking a lot more time okay let me
switch back to my trace window here and
see what happened
I'm gonna quickly refresh this
stackdriver console so this is my trace
from just now and click on the trace and
see what happened you can see that it
attempted to connect to Redis and it
failed and it went to my sequel so
something happened that caused it to
close the close the connection and I can
also see in my stackdriver console that
errors are starting to show up and I can
trigger alerts based on this error as
well what I've done here is I've set up
an alert that says if there are if
there's more than one error in my you
know for this particular metric that I'm
surfacing send me an email you can also
have it connect to page or duty or any
other a whole slew of other integration
points so hopefully that gives you a
sense of what you can do with open
census there's a lot of power here let's
actually switch back to the slide since
we don't have a lot of time I'm gonna
reckon wrap things up as I mentioned if
you go to this link you can find a whole
bunch of libraries that are already
instrumented Genesis one of them there
are a couple of gold libraries in there
and please do ad open census
integrations or instrumentations on your
own and contribute it back yeah there's
a whole lot more to come you know with
memory stores go Paul mentioned I'll
hand it over to a real quick
so just to quickly wrap up so what we
discussed here and talked about is the
overview of Club memory store there are
a lot of questions in terms of feature
sets that that you want to see that's
something like I said we're actually
working on this is the first version of
the product if you really really care
about something we do have something
called the issue tracker where you can
actually log your requests we actively
take a look at all the issues or
requests that comes in in terms of
feature requests so I really really
encourage you to please do that if there
are things that you feel are super
important for you to use the service but
just in closing thank you all for being
here thank you for coming to Google
cloud next we really appreciate you
taking the time but if you have any more
questions we have the engineering team
here also so we'll hang around and if
you have any more questions we are happy
to take those thank you very much
[Music]